thank you
so dan two o'clock on uh the first
oh okay yeah so it's i think just two
o'clock
time for everybody
i got on some some email list where they
keep sending me job opportunities and
why not know
that was my hand thing that i kept under
my seat
this year yeah i put it there oh i'm
sorry that's all right
missiles and oil yeah
fossil fuels
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
if i remember how to do this
[Music]
i'm good thank you
hi for organization
cbs is coming do you see cbs
okay come on in
so here's the subscribe right here
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
good are you
there
[Music]
the clock i mean it'll just be two of us
plus this guy and we'll be moving around
but not right there's nothing
out of us yeah i get it for this room
but it's also for the house tv studio
no he's here today
until they're not alone you know
no pawns tuesday thursday
[Music]
um
yes
it's just generally easier to park first
than walk them over
oh sure drive over there
what
okay here we go
[Music]
huh
is
uh
[Music]
time for me to retire
that's right
i wrote today and could hear you yelling
in my head
a lot harder
what's that
oh
hmm
is
okay
[Music]
uh
that's cool
no
their faces
is
oh
next
uh
[Music]
foreign
journalists are you okay if
whatever senator speaking removes their
mask when they speak
you guys feel yeah
she went through the long
okay
his name carry this [ __ ] which one is it
it's a not a popular brand
okay you can get it on amazon so i don't
repeat
that everybody started carrying like
everything
still it's still big enough that they
put too much
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
okay i have been told that all the
journalists
and everybody else who's here um is okay
if i take off my mask when i speak
raise your hand if it's okay that's not
a fair question
she told me beforehand it is a fair
question and we're doing it
okay um
she mentioned it to me before i was just
checking that it was all everyone was
here
yes okay good afternoon everyone thanks
for coming
and democrats are so proud that the
american rescue plan is already
delivering help to millions of americans
we said before help is on the way now we
can say
help is here help is here because
democrats are delivering on our promises
just as we
uh said in the campaign democrats
promise
put us in office you'll get checks
they're getting checks
put us in office the vaccines will start
coming forward
now over 2.4 million shots are being
administered a day
put us in office and we'll do something
about child poverty
the american rescue plan cuts poverty in
half
we're helping feed the hungry we're
helping people stay in their homes
terrorists members of the biden cabinet
are barnstorming the country
to tout what's in the bill democrats
kept our promise and we're delivering
real help to working americans
something not even talked about the
pensions
last week a gentleman construction
worker
depending on his pension actually a
teamster but he
works in construction depending on his
pension
was teary-eyed he said if my pension
goes down
if not i don't mind that it hurts me it
hurts my spam my wife
my children my parents they're all
depending on me please
save it we've saved we've saved
so we're doing our job as promised when
we got into office
when we became the majority everyone
said how they're going to get it all
done
you got to confirm the cabinet you got
to try do an impeachment trial and pass
aarp well
we have done an impeachment trial we
passed arp
and with the nomination of mr walsh
every
cabinet secretary will have been
installed all 16.
so we've kept our promise and so many
other good things
native americans have far too long been
neglected at the cabinet level
now there's a strong voice in deb
holland
now they have a seat at the table small
business needs money
is isabel guzman is being confirmed as
small business administrator
we have to have a much tougher stronger
policy against china
catherine tai will be confirmed as trade
rep
and on thursday we'll confirm javier
becerra
to be hhs secretary and the house will
send us a bipartisan bill on ppp
we senate democrats support it
unanimously we want it to move as
quickly as possible i just hope
our senate republican friends will agree
to pass
the ppp extension without delay
so that small businesses that need our
help won't fall through the cracks
senator durbin
let me put my mask back on
and senator durbin with or without mass
as
of his son's mask as we say
12 years ago you remember when mitch
mcconnell
pronounced the beginning of the obama
administration the one-term presidency
and then set out to deny any republican
votes for anything obama wanted
it went on and on and on for months and
even years
it was frustrating to be a senator even
worse to be an american
looking to the senate for results so
what plan do the republicans have
in this round it appears it's the same
mcconnell playbook
we are not going to play we are not
going to participate
and look what happened we passed the
american rescue plan without him
the american people now get a look at
what mitch mcconnell
and his senate republicans refused to
support
it addresses the most fundamental
concerns families have across america
first the pandemic second the economy
and third a myriad of other issues
whether it's schools ready for kids
or whether it's individuals that receive
enough cash to make it through the next
few months
these are the bottom line issues for
america and mcconnell
stays on the sidelines he refuses to
participate
i hope he's wrong i hope enough
republicans decide this is not
the right approach that they'll join us
in bipartisan efforts
there are many things we can't do by
reconciliation we need a bipartisan
approach
and i hope they'll see that in the best
interest of this country for us to come
together
and the argument that this bill this
american rescue plan
with 1.9 trillion or so is full of pork
is full of beans when you get down to it
this bill really does what it says it
does
it helps the americans directly no
sleight of hand
no hidden tricks it just basically comes
through with the money when they need it
it's not only good for them it's not a
good for our communities but it's good
for america
the economists tell us we need to get up
off the floor and move forward again
together
we're going to do it with the american
rescue plan
thank you i've been thinking a lot
lately about something that vice
president kamal harris
said recently she made the point and i'm
paraphrasing
that well we've got to get back to
normal when it comes to things like
sending our kids off to school safely or
hugging our kids and grandkids who
aren't in the same household
visiting family from out of town and
just not having to worry about a
terrifying deadly virus we've also got
to recognize that going
back to normal doesn't make sense when
normal wasn't working
in the first place normal hasn't been
working well for working parents
especially moms even before this
pandemic
normal wasn't working for communities of
color and tribes
who faced deeply harmful long-standing
inequities across
health care and education and economic
opportunity
long before this pandemic started normal
hasn't been working for our essential
workers many of them who kept our
country running
this year while making poverty level
wages
or people with disabilities who've long
faced ableism and inequity when it comes
to
accessing health care getting a job or
receiving a quality education
i could go on but what i'm glad of is
the american
rescue plan will help our country not
just get back to normal
but set a course towards a fairer
stronger country and economy
where all of our families and
communities can succeed
not those just at the top expanding
access to affordable
child care direct payments tax relief
for families
making health care more affordable and
so much more that's in the american
rescue plan
are ways to help our families weather
the storm of covet 19
and ensure our economy works for all of
us we've got a lot of work ahead
and we are far from the finish line when
it comes to cobia 19
but we are going to stay clear-eyed
about the challenges that we face
make sure the biden harris
administration is fully staffed
and able to able to put in and all of
their all into ending this pandemic
and continue putting workers and
families first in everything we do
thank you
thank you help really has arrived for
the majority of people in our country
and
certainly for the majority people in
michigan and that's what i want to speak
to for a moment consider a single mom
who has two young children a
three-year-old and a six-year-old
she lost her job a number of months ago
because of the pandemic
she's been worried sick wondering how
she's going to pay the rent
keep the heat on which becomes an issue
in michigan in the winter
as well as making sure that lights are
on
and buy groceries for her children well
today
things have changed for that michigan
mom
when she checked her bank account today
she had an additional four thousand
two hundred dollars in her bank account
just think about what that means she can
make the rent
she can pay some critical bills even buy
some new shoes for her children who seem
to go out of them every single week
and that's just the beginning because
the american rescue plan goes
far beyond fourteen hundred dollar
checks this mom has been surviving
on unemployment and now she knows that
this support will last until september
and she'll continue to get
an additional 300 a week like so many
other americans when she lost her job
she lost her health care
not anymore the american rescue plan
is paying for her cobra payment for the
next six months
she no longer has to worry about her
family that they'll lose their home
because the american rescue plan
provides emergency aid
to cover back rent and she's less
worried
that they'll go hungry because snap
benefits
alone have increased by about 75 dollars
a month for her family
which is critically important when she
goes to the grocery store
the american rescue plan also helps
cover the cost of child care so she can
have some help while she's doing a job
interview
and she's relieved that her first grader
is going to be able to go back to school
full-time
because his teachers and his bus driver
and the other people that work at the
school will be able to get vaccinated
and they'll address other safety
measures
under the funds in the american rescue
plan
so today a lot has changed
for this michigan mom she no longer
feels alone
she feels like somebody's got her back
for this michigan mom and so many others
help has arrived
i'd like to just i thought my colleagues
gave well patty
debbie dick great great talks good job
yes uh if you have a response to leader
mcconnell saying today that
a change in the cloture rules would turn
the senate into a hundred car pileup
with nothing moving and secondly
on that point do you agree with senator
durbin's view that the filibuster
has become okay let me answer both first
senator mcconnell is always looking for
a diversion
he knows how popular arp is he knows he
and his whole caucus opposed it
and that the american people even
republicans we just survey in new york
state 55 percent of republicans are for
the arp now that it's passed
so he's always looking for a diversion
as for
the issue we democrats all of us believe
we need big
bold change as i've said before we hope
our republican colleagues will work with
us to produce that change
we will try to get them to work with us
but if not
we will put our heads together and
figure out how to go and everything is
on the table
after this slate of cabinet nominations
is finished
is it your intention to put your china
bill on the floor
immediately and will it have the support
of the necessary ten or so republicans
well first we are going to sit down
and talk to the our caucus is going to
sit down and talk together about where
we should go next right now we're still
filling the president's cabinet the last
few nominees and that'll take this week
and next week as well as passing ppp
but we will sit down as a caucus and
with the biden administration and decide
exactly where to go next we have a lot
of things we want to do
on the china bill we have good
bipartisan support on that we are
my instructions to every one of the
chairs
um who's working on the china bill is to
work with your republican colleagues the
centerpiece is a bipartisan
proposal the endless frontiers act
proposed by myself and todd young of
indiana and he's very enthusiastic
uh the semiconductor piece is bipartisan
a lot of the other parts of it are
bipartisan
and we hope to have it as a bipartisan
bill she's next
um mr leader two questions one on the
issue of immigration obviously there's
an emerging crisis
at the border but why don't you think
that there
is the will right now to fix it in a big
way
in your chamber i mean just yesterday
senator durbin said that there's
little chance of passing the president's
bill so what do
you think we believe look i i think the
president's bill is great
and as you know it's not that different
from the bill that senator mccain and i
worked in the senate with the gang of
uh eight that durbin was a member of it
um
and so we're going to try to do
everything we can for as bold an
immigration bill as we can get
plain and simple we'll see where our
republican colleagues are
next next no no no no on on friday you
called on governor cuomo to resign but
earlier in the day you would not reach
that point
what changed for you over the last
several hours to reach that
as i've said uh new york state
under this covet crisis needs safe and
uh
they need secure and safe and strong
leadership the women have come forward
i'm proud they have
they've made some serious allegations
and they should be listened to
because the governor because of these
allegations
the governor has lost the confidence
of his governing partners and of many
new yorkers and he should step down have
you spoken
on the immigration questions
isn't though aren't there divides in
your caucus you said yesterday senator
durbin
that the situation the border made it
harder to move the bill
and and you said you know the bill is
similar
to the minister's bill similar to bill
13 year in 2013
but we're dealing with a border issue
now therefore shouldn't that reflect
what is going on there now and to your
point does that make it
it's challenge and the new
administration deserves an opportunity
to respond to
it and i think it's going to be part of
the conversation about immigration
let's assume for a second they're
successful in doing it and six weeks
from now
we don't have a situation that's as
challenging as the one today
does that mean the republicans have come
forward for immigration reform
i'm not sure but i think we need to deal
with this reality at the border
i said to the administration come
forward with your plan marcus is
testifying maybe tomorrow
in the house of representatives and i'm
looking forward to what his suggestions
are we want to work together
you know one question each yeah
my strongest desire is to pass
comprehensive immigration reform i felt
that way since 2013 when the house
blocked it
and we'll do everything we can to
explore that area um the house hasn't
sent us the comprehensive bill yet
uh they're in the process of sending us
other legislation we again
want to get to do as much as we can
to make immigrants welcome in america
to make sure that america uh integrates
immigrants into our system of government
and we'll keep fighting to get as bold
and strong a bill as we can
yes next we've spent some time now
talking about the challenge of
immigration we've talked about
uh infrastructure i'm curious with
chairman sanders suggesting perhaps
budget reconciliation needs to be used
on a transportation infrastructure bill
what do you see getting done in the
senate on a traditional sort of 60-vote
margin well as i said we're going to try
to work with republicans wherever we can
the china bill is a bill there are
others bipartisan bills that
are we're talking to our republican
colleagues about and when we can work
with our republican friends
we will but we must get bold change
and if our republican friends block it
uh we're going to put our heads together
and figure out
the best way to go everything's on the
table it's plain and simple
okay thank you everybody
you